let's talk a bit about two-factor
authentication or multi-factor
authentication anytime where you have a
password usually a password didn't have
to be and then they ask you something
else like to verify your identity so
maybe they send you a one-time password
through a text or maybe you have to use
an app like Google Authenticator to
produce a one-time number if I want to
login to my online banking I have to put
my card and top my pin into a device
which produces me a one-time password
it's just kind of idea everyone I think
has a kind of intuitive idea of what the
point of two factor is but let's sort of
try and formalize it a bit and break
down what it's good for and what it's
not good for and you know exactly what
we're getting from it that we wouldn't
otherwise have the point of
authentication is to verify to some
server it's usually remote or your
machine that you are who you say you are
and so in essence your vene allowed to
access the things on that machine or on
that device passwords seem to be what
we've settled on as a kind of happy
medium they are something we know by I
have some knowledge but hopefully no one
else has and that means that I can type
that in and verify it must be me because
I'm the only one that knows what that is
right if you want to know about what
happens when other people know those
things then see the other videos we've
done on this because I've talked about
partners before so if your password is
six characters long it's being fat right
now and it's being packed quickly
because we can go through all with six
character passwords in a fraction of a
second passwords are not foolproof right
people pick bad ones and they get hacked
they even they can pick good ones and
they still get hacked because it's like
a key logger maybe a key log or
something like this that's where to fact
or multi-factor authentication comes in
so usually we talk about these three
things we can use to demonstrate that we
are who we say we are so we have
something we know a password or
something else a date of birth a
mother's maiden name these are kind of
common ones people go for something we
have my our mobile phone receiving a
text message or credit card or something
like this or something we are now
something we are is less common but this
would be biometrics or fingerprints you
know iris recognition voice recognition
if we're going a bit more out there gait
recognition that's how you walk things
like this usually demonstrating who you
are has some kind of hardware involved
so is less common
we're gonna put it aside for today what
we do is we combine something we know
with something we have to make it that
much harder for someone that finds out
that thing we know can break into our
account all right so let's assume for a
minute that someone's guessed my
password
they don't have possession of my phone
hopefully we don't need a pin code on
the phone they don't have the app on the
phone so they can't answer that question
when asked so when they try and log in
they get the password correct but they
can't get the second part of the puzzle
and that has two benefits first of all
they can't compromise the account but
also if someone's logged in successfully
of a password but unsuccessfully with
the other part of the to factor that
could flag a warning that then sends an
email to the user to say just check your
password hasn't been compromised if your
password is compromised even if it's not
your fault they stopped someone breaking
into your account this is why it's quite
common on things like password managers
online banking and other you know some
email systems and in fact a lot of
computer systems these days we'll see
multi-factor authentication being used
but that isn't to say that it's always a
good idea right there's this sort of
opinion perhaps in security circles
about more security is always better and
that I bought the agree with in general
but of course you have to consider ease
of use you have to consider that some of
these people aren't experts and they
haven't got that much time to be
constantly checking their mobile for
extra texts and things maybe they're
trying to do this somewhere where there
isn't any reception you can't just put
on extra layers of security and it not a
little bit hinder what people are trying
to do I think the idea of multi-factor
authentication is to have a compromise
between the additional security offers
and it being a total pain and never
actually getting anything done you know
so for example on some software you'll
find that it only asks let's say for
multi-factor for logging in on a new
device and once you've logged in it will
allow you to persist that that session
for a while things like this the idea
being that it's somewhat inconvenient
but it doesn't get a bit silly about it
all right because this can come back and
get you someone pointing this out to me
when I was talking about this on on
Twitter and you know that they had a lot
of friends who accidentally been kicked
off whatever observer because they've
the device that was producing -
something they have and that's actually
happened to me I used Google
Authenticator to log onto one of my
servers and I lost my phone because it
got broken and it went off to repairs
and for those two weeks I'd completely
forgotten
I mean you smash your phone the last
thing you're thinking about is all I
must save my Google Authenticator
passwords you're not thinking about that
it's gone and then you realize actually
I can't log into my Twitter or my or my
server for two weeks right in the end I
had to in the end I had to go in via the
terminal on the server and reset the
Authenticator password because we should
bit of a pain so you can imagine it's
quite easy to lock yourself out because
you can lose that thing you have so you
know multi-factor authentication is a
really good thing and people should be
using it where security is a concern
right but it's not a completely
foolproof replacement for good passwords
and you can't really realistically use
it on every single system you have
unless you're just unbelievably willing
to put up with you know inconvenience
right if you much more patient than me
because I you know I can't do it I
supposed to clarify two-factor
authentication is a subset of
multi-factor authentication which could
have any number of authentication
mechanisms you could imagine combining
all three of these you see that on the
movies quite a lot where they look into
something with their I then they speak
out loud or maybe they also type in a
password
[Music]
it's going to take an ages to log into
anything but you know that's the idea so
a good example is the is the hash based
one-time password or one-time password
right which is at the core of Google
Authenticator and numerous other tools
for generating these things so we're
talking about you type in a password
that you know and then some device you
have generates a different password but
only it has only used that one time and
unless you know both of those things at
the same time you're not getting in
that's the idea so I actually have
Google Authenticator so I can show you
broadly what it is there are lots of
alternatives like free one-time password
and another numerous other apps you can
search for but do this all what I've got
here is Google Authenticator every 30
seconds rotating these one-time
passwords so you can see this little
countdown here when it gets to the
bottom it'll generate another set of
passwords and then I have to type in
that password
whenever I log in so how does that work
well let's just talk a little bit about
how it works in actual fact it basically
ties back into our message
authentication codes that we were
talking about in a previous video right
we had H Mac with a key would be used to
generate two sub keys but we won't dwell
on that and a message in hash based
one-time passwords or H OTP we actually
calculate the age Mac of a secret key s
and a counter that we're counting up
right so the first time I log into this
website the counter will be 0 or 1 it's
not important right but obviously my
device but I'm using to generate these
one-time passwords and the server have
to be on the same number the secret key
we've shared beforehand hopefully not in
plain text to everyone
all right so it'll be able some long
string that a server gave me when I
first created my account or when I first
set up this authentication system the
idea is that we're combining our secret
key that only means a server know with
whatever the counter currently is to
generate a one-off hash which is then
essentially shortened and turned into a
small number the way we do that is we
take certain bytes from the H Mac
because that's going to be for example
for an H Mac of a sha-1 that's going to
be
60 bits so we take four bytes from here
we calculate those four bytes modulo 10
to the D where D is how many decimal we
want right so on my Google Authenticator
I was using six so your authentication
app would have a certain number of
digits the output and what would happen
is the server when you log in will
perform the exact same calculation
because they know were two things that
we do they know the secret key and they
know the counter right now I'll get on
to exact because Google Authenticator
extends this to use time and we'll talk
about that in a moment but the thing the
interesting thing about this is in
actual fact it's really a second
password alright this secret key is a
big long password that we have that is
stored on my phone or my other device
and stored on the server so in some
sense that can also be compromised it's
still vulnerable to fishing and many
other security issues the problem with
this like it's quite widely used the
problem is but it you might accidentally
get out of sync let's imagine that you
generate one of these one-time passwords
but then someone phones you up and you
get distracted and you wander off right
then you generate another one
try login and you have sync and we've
got a real problem so we're gonna check
use instead and this is what Google
Authenticator does is use totp or a
time-based one-time password so always
happening here if we're placing our
increment encounter with the current
time alright so that as long as me in
the server roughly at the same time we
can log in we still keep this shared
secret between ourselves there's
obviously a few niggly details that we
have to consider here so first of all we
you know what unit of time we're using
we can't use milliseconds because the
chance of me in a server being on the
same number of milliseconds is
astronomically low and I can't type in
the one-time password in a millisecond
from it to be I mean I could type pretty
far No so what we do is we let's say
round to the nearest or floor to the
nearest 30 seconds so what you would do
is you would take the unix time number
part on use time right so you know link
somewhere buried deep down inside that
system there's a little counter but that
unix time divided by let's say 30 okay
and then the floor function which
basically goes down to the nearest
integer so what we're saying there is in
thirty-second blocks generate a unique
number right which in essence replaces
this counter right we still use an
h-back as before now
in practice in case they're out by let's
say a minute or two minutes
we might calculate on the server side C
+ 1 C minus 1 just to see if they're ok
they're close enough right so for
example when like when I look at the
password on my app if it's about to
expire I can still type it in because
even if it's just expired it'll still be
allowed right and it's a security
parameter of these systems is how what
the window size is so I'm just
oversimplifying this slightly actually
we can subtract a start time here like
the default is zero which is what I
haven't bothered to talk about it but
you can agree with the server a time to
start and you essentially take unix time
- whatever your start time is but let's
not get into too much you know in too
much pedantic time zones right yeah I
mean time zones caused a problem here
yeah I know right
accounting we had a video on that from
the bank I think due for ease of a
technical term very similar so what
happened so smart cards were actually to
pass a little bit smarter than people
think and they actually perform
encryption and all kinds of things what
that machine will do is essentially a
challenge response it will send them a
request of a card for it to perform a
certain cryptographic function the card
asks for the pin you supply a pin and it
performs a punk function which is then
turned into a a one-time password right
so it basically verifies that you are
both in possession of your card and have
the pin which is good news other banks
will work on this kind of principle with
a time-based system and hopefully they
ask you plenty of time so in my bank to
log in I have to use this device and
then to send any money I also have to
use this device and this stops the old
the classic replay attack and time of
check time of use issues where I've
logged in wandered off stupidly left my
online banking logged in and then
someone has at all my money which would
be if not quite as much as they'd like
I've always had a slight concern with
the multi-factor authentication they've
used in Star Trek where they read out
their password allowed operation in
front of everyone else I mean okay yes
so the voice recognition part of it
there's something they have maybe you
can't steal that but now everyone knows
your password it's hope they may take
them daily I'm sure they've solved it by
then that we release their problems